hello and welcome to this video playing
webmasters smoke it does he have a name
in there nope not a good score here and
minus two playing a unconventional line
here in them the Sicilian yeah shooting
shooting for something different um okay
who I think here you go here go with 96
but I'm really kind of inventing things
here over the board I don't really know
the theoretical details him okay I
probably claim to be am covering d6
let's move I didn't understand frankly
speaking out is six what is the idea
going back to a three Wow okay so what
now even beef before he goes where all
the way back I guess okay let's do it
right a 4 that's 94 and wide resigns so
he probably has to go through d1 maybe
Queen B 6 was actually stronger
attending 23 I can't again a move I
didn't consider at all yeah how to do it
92 94 might and might come whom I would
love to prevent him from castling it
would be really nice and not so easy to
do I think I'll just push the pawns
ok so these ideas to to take only six
now would you like to use the e5 square
yeah okay if I was an interesting move
okay I should speed up this is a clear
danger in this position I have many
interesting options and now if I spend
too much time we know the deal so yeah
if i take it on a 5 I mean you will play
85 so what now 95 is even a move here I
don't know if that's an idea it takes
the six I have discoveries and okay
okay so um d5 if you place fy6 huh this
is just about working
will be six is also a good move our an
interesting move at least 25 f is six ok
let's go Queen B 6 I can go push it be
six actually Oh f 23 I guess okay how
very tough very tough I came this one
check i'm starting with the check and
then see what happens
okay not this place okay I'm taking this
and then see what happens Queen f4 just
give those chicks so anything better
chattin getting down on time so take a
form if someone is hanging at the end
check
oh I can actually go to be one that's
stupid do I really have no better move
than look a 7 in this position think
it's really the case okay
check time morning
for the name up to five now I think and
roped you too
maybe I should play group chief I've
don't really know okay I've group of
Queen here right check really blind
sometimes it's it's terrible pawn takes
and it's made right check White Rose I
yes it takes me ages sometimes to spot
those those simple tactics I mean
técnicas their strong word for that Wow
I have no idea i mean what i know is
that this is a pretty that this is a
pred pretty bad move I mean it just
completely miss places White's pieces
but I probably have better options um
then what I did this is maybe already
questionable if this is the best one the
computer gives couldn't be six and this
is this is probably better because it
keeps the queenside structure more solid
and I have still this idiom rook c8 and
this is a very good Ricky terraza
position where white has lost tons of
times with his knights ok auntie em well
it's it's still probably good for black
but it's very murky ok five fancy move
but it did looked interesting and yeah
Jim yeah I took the engine wants to play
rook c5 and gives me a good position
also interesting but I didn't didn't see
that move yeah this is this is looking
good but there is f takes he can he can
really just egg it looks good at first
like a double attack but it doesn't work
this is what I did and now it took only
six
check yeah this is this I thought that
the most likely i cannot come with a
drawer here check HERE Queen takes e4
was just winning check I didn't do
didn't see that I mean I didn't go for
that I don't don't don't understand why
it is winning probably because some know
why let's say and something like this
Bishop h6 I because I can take g2g okay
i can take jen this is the thing ok so
maybe king d 1 i can take with the Queen
ah this is the simple point ah wow wow
yeah and this chat 55 ok as I didn't
consider that I didn't see Queen texts
six at all I was just thinking check do
to tack on the dark squares this is also
a lot better black though check this
Queen f2 is also good but this is also
winning Jade takes and drooped you to
win black wins here yeah this is a bit
too strong it's already made and then
the engine seized are made in five which
I didn't I only thought that I thought
that must be dangerous but it was
actually a maid in five Wow very wild
game okay thanks for watching